[Music]
so in a covid world we've been focused
on safety yep
almost all of us choose to engage in
activities from swimming in the sea to
driving a car or having a bottle of wine
that carry risks
in fact more people died globally last
year from alcohol than from covid
so how do we assess what risks to take
and how much time and resource to
protect ourselves from future risk
while it looks as if vaccines will bring
the coveted pandemic under control
the next pandemic is potentially just a
virus away
must we act urgently now to safeguard
safeguard the world further from a
future catastrophe or should we assess
this against other global risks and then
the cost and the resource involved
is our ultimate goal to eradicate risk
or must we just accept that risk is
unavoidable
well we've got a great panel to discuss
this here beverly taylor is a biochemist
she's head of influencer and scientific
affairs at sakuras and is an expert on
global vaccine production and the inner
workings of the who ella whelan is a
political commentator and freelance
journalist
her criticism of no platforming and 21st
century feminism has caused her to clash
with mainstream journalists on the bbc
sky and channel 4
and her first book is what women want
fun freedom and an end to feminism
lawrence phillips who likes to be called
larry
is an emeritus professor of
decision sciences at the london school
of economics and a director of
facilitations limited
uh after a career beginning in
electrical engineering and three years
in the u.s navy larry has become a
leading expert in decision science with
decades of experience studying risk so
as you all know the formula is that each
of our guests here has three minutes to
to do a pitch on the first question
which is
in the context of the pandemic how do we
assess what risks to take and how much
time and resource to protect ourselves
from future risk beverly i'm going to
start with you okay thank you
as we all know we've just come through a
devastating pandemic which isn't quite
over yet
had huge
impact on the economy as well as public
health and
social
health
and
you know i do believe that we've got to
be prepared for that um i think we need
um to be prepared i think we need
robust surveillance of what viruses are
emerging
and i think we need robust health
systems um for everybody so that all
though the preparedness activities can
be implemented
um i i i don't want to leave people with
the impression that there is no
preparedness because who actually
works to
carry out surveillance globally to look
for emerging viruses and this is an
ongoing program i work on influenza
and there are 155 labs worldwide in 125
different countries
that year round day after day are
carrying out surveillance for influenza
viruses not only the seasonal viruses
but the emerging viruses and those
emerging viruses
coming from that can potentially cause a
pandemic
come from the animal human interface so
the surveillance at that interface is a
real opportunity for us to pick
something up really early so that we can
start building the preparedness in
and governments have also been prepared
so if you look at the uk government we
have
we have like a risk
register for the uk and influenza is
right up there at the top
as it is in many other countries
and the uk government has got
preparedness plans the problem is they
were really focused on a pandemic
influenza and not for covid19
so
we've had a contract with the uk since
2012 to supply vaccines if it was
influenza and we've got contracts with
other countries so this is something
that that has been thought about
and a lot of the things that were put in
place
that people won't be aware of at all but
um actually got used for the kovid
response so the who preparation the
whole system the whole network that
they've got for influenza was actually
used to carry out surveillance for
covid19 so that's how we knew we know
that the new variants are coming out
that's how we can develop new diagnostic
kits work on second generation vaccines
the same in the uk you know the robust
supply chains
um the stockpiles of vials and syringes
and and the fact that we have
a vaccine that we make every year
means that in the case of influenza we
could just have switched that over and
made a vaccine much more quickly than we
could for covid because we already do
that every year
unfortunately in this case it happened
to be covered and not influenza but
still that preparedness made a
difference and i think we have to keep
thinking about that
so important to be prepared for whatever
comes our way but if it's if it's a
respiratory virus or something else a
lot of the preparedness plans that we
have already in place for influenza
could be utilized for a pandemic
response
okay that's interesting i'm sure we'll
come back to that uh ella i think that
the there's practical questions about
how you prepare
um to prevent against the negative ways
in which risks can affect you and
completely agree with everything you've
just said in relation to making sure
there is the
materials there for us to prepare for a
future pandemic but i suppose what i
might put forward is the question of
politically how we deal with risk and i
really think that you should we should
flip the question on its head that the
balance for too long has been too far
swayed in favor of preventing against
risk rather than thinking about what we
need to do to maneuver towards a life
and a politics of greater freedom
and this balance between safety and
being concerned with risk and freedom uh
has been very much tilted one way
throughout the pandemic obviously uh in
the early stages of the pandemic and
when it was the virus was at its worst
for very good reasons and uh doing
preventative things like lockdown
measures to
help protect nhs from being overrun or
indeed protect the elderly from dying as
many of the as many of them did was a
was a beneficial balancing of that risk
versus freedom sort of swaying but i
think that risk prevention as we come
out of the pandemic we really have to
think about the way in which we have
pathologized risk have we now consider
risk to be in some an insurmountable
challenge something that we must almost
in always prevent against i mean i know
that there's a war going on a bit of a
kind of cultural going on about vaccine
passports um across europe but
particularly in the uk you know the
government flip-flopping on whether or
not they're going to have it there being
a very good example of where the idea of
risk overcomes and the prevention of
risk overcomes the need to think about
civil liberties and freedom
but i think the crucial thing to think
about when we're considering
how important the idea of risk is or
maybe the beneficial parts of risk is to
understand that this phenomenon of us
dealing with risk as a kind of an evil
something to be warded off hasn't just
fallen from the sky during the pandemic
it's actually come out of political
trends that have been long in the making
so they are you know kind of
from sort of banal things if you want to
think of it in our way like anti-smoking
laws or interventions in relation to
public health being about pathologizing
risk at the expense of individual
freedom there's been that trend
on a more political level throughout the
pandemic there's been the government has
implemented bans on protest bans on
freedom of speech online in the way in
which coronavirus or vaccines or
whatever can be talked about and that
has happened uh for decades previously
through institution
bans on um freedom and speech and
freedom of debate i mean the current
police crime and prevention bill that's
pretty much pretty patel cracking down
on protest is all part of that sense of
risk involves trusting people to make
decisions and what we really are saying
in society is that we can't trust people
to make decisions there's the kind of
practical aversion to risk you know that
we we should police what people eat in
case there's the risk that if they're
allowed to eat what they want they
become a drain on the nhs and are obese
and fat there's a psychological aversion
to risk you know we've we often talk
about particularly in education the risk
of marking kids work with a red pen or
telling them that they're wrong or
disciplining them in case it causes some
kind of psychological harm along the way
and then as i've already mentioned
there's political risk i mean i was just
on a panel yesterday about descent and
democracy one of the biggest problems we
have in contemporary politics is a as a
misbelief in trusting people to take
risks when it comes to political
opinions to try out this discussions to
try out ideas and free debates we what
we want to do is flip risk on its head
and think sensibly about it and think
that one of you know what beverly
mentioned one of the most amazing things
to come out of this pandemic has been
the vaccine and i'm no epidemiologist or
a scientist and know anything like that
i know a little bit from being a saint
john's ambulance volunteer vaccinator a
tiny bit but the you know the whole
exciting thing about that is that taking
risks and innovating in the world of
science for example is part of progress
you can't experiment you can't make
mistakes you can't learn lessons unless
you inherently embrace the positives of
risk so i think we should think about
what
what shunning risk and embracing safety
in expense of freedom leaves us in terms
of political change and progress in
society
thanks very much larry
well
i have a problem about all this because
you're talking about taking risks i
actually you don't take risks
i don't set out to take risks what i do
is i make decisions and you said that
ella we take decisions not risks risks
are a consequence so why what what did i
make what choices did i make in the
light of code well
when we take decisions we take decisions
because
we want to make something better
we have a goal
an objective and my objective my
fundamental objective is to stay alive
so
i have another objective and that's to
help other people as a decision analyst
i do a lot of that
so
i decided yes i would get vaccinated
right
so i've helped myself to stay alive and
i've helped you to stay alive as well
i don't see
that
there can be any doubt about that but
obviously there is in some people's
minds
and that may be because they have
different objectives
so i think we have to look at the
objectives of what it is we're trying to
to uh to do and you you talked about
political objectives and other
objectives yes they're all these but
fundamentally
what do we do we take decisions
let me tell you a little short story my
father
smoked most of his life
when he was 70 years old my sister
who was a nurse took him through the
emphysema ward
of the local hospital
and as he left he turned to her and said
oh my god they're our better and worse
ways to die
he quit smoking immediately and lived to
be 96. oh brilliant so
so he had another objective
which was the quality of his life and we
take decisions to do those things we
don't take risks
we accept risk
amounts
but let's focus on what we should be
doing and what the objectives are that
we are looking at
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas